let's turn back to politics and the
republican convention kevin mccarthy is
the
california's top gop lawmaker he's also
the house minority
leader he joins us tonight mr leader
thanks for being here thanks for having
me back
you know democrats portraying last night
had a lot of things to say today the
biggest was
it's an alternative reality that
republicans are living in
your response to that i think last night
was wonderful
i think it exemplified that it's okay to
be excited about america
when you sit there and look at massimo
nikki haley
tim scott how powerful it didn't matter
what party you were in you were proud as
an american
you were excited for what this nation
been able to achieve an
uplifting spirit something that you did
not see in the four nights of the
democrat convention
the other thing that a lot of democrats
are having a problem with is tonight's
one of tonight's speakers and that's
secretary pompeo from
israel take a listen to this
for him to do this i think uh further
shows that
uh this administration is willing to
politicize
uh the state of israel uh and use it uh
as a political wedge as opposed to a
rallying cry for us to come together and
continue
our traditions of bipartisan support for
the state of israel
to me it's it's reckless as the
secretary himself
cautioned employees at the state
department that they should not be
engaged
in any partisan activities because they
work for the state department
and now he's doing just that
your response i have to laugh at speaker
pelosi
because mike pompeo is doing this on his
own
time no government funding is being
spent but you know what we're spending
government money on
we're spending government money on 68
democrats who refuse to show up
to the emergency session that we had
last saturday
but you never heard one word from
speaker pelosi
secretary pompeo this is on his own time
he is working just as the job that he
always does
so at any given moment if you would have
asked
mike pompeo to do a video on his own
he would be somewhere in the world and i
think that it's good that we can hear
about
the work that he is doing only bringing
our allies stronger together
in this administration just continuing
to keep their promise speaker pelosi
this week
said the president is a domestic enemy
in the constitution
saying you the gop on capitol hill fall
under domestic
enemy and that it's shameful enemy of
the state
how are you going to negotiate with
speaker pelosi in that environment and
is there any backlash
for not getting something across the
finish line as far as that negotiation
goes
that's a great question last time they
called us the deplorables
now speaker pelosi is saying we're an
enemy
if you want to know why there is no
agreement yet when it comes to a new
covet bill
you heard directly from her remember
every time we tried to move
legislation from the very first cares
act when she came in to hold it up
or when we needed more money for the
small business employees
she stood in front of her refrigerator
and said no to the nation
she's doing that exact same thing now
she always puts politics before people
and that's what's wrong we need people
who can work together and that's exactly
what you saw last night
from a democrat state rep from georgia
standing up saying he's supporting the
president and getting criticized and
they want him to
resign from every walk of life it was a
right to try to saved somebody's life
with a drug because what this president
has done
that's why i think at the end of the day
when people see the four days of the
republican convention
and four days of the democratic
convention it will be very clear
that we have a big contrast in an agenda
after the democrat convention there's
only three things i know
they hate president trump they want to
raise your taxes and they want to defund
the police
we love america and an idea that we
think this is an exceptional country
a more perfect union that can take a
life of a tim scott that can go from
cotton to congress in one generation i
mean in one lifetime
that's amazing or nikki haley these are
the stories of america and what bring
people to a party of lincoln and which
sits and folds that the next four years
will even be better than the four before
you are correct that we've heard a lot
of policy jammed into even just the
first night of the rnc
and and there was criticism that the dnc
didn't have a lot of specifics in policy
however
there is also not a republican platform
new york magazine writes it this way
why would the party and its candidates
running for office at every level define
themselves so thoroughly
with the president who has never even
briefly held the support of half the
country
it's probably because trump is so deeply
and historically unpopular
that his party has embraced him so
tightly as far as
lack of a platform that's where the new
york magazine is writing
why is there not a platform well well
that first that's just not true and if
they wanted to put that equation
bill clinton how much did he did he went
by 43
or something if you sit and look at a
platform yeah because we're sitting in
the middle of covid because i'm
the chair of the convention as well we
were just down in charlotte we just
agreed to the platform that we had
before because you couldn't bring
everybody together
but you know another contrast between
the republican and democrat convention
our nominees actually showed up to the
location
to accept the vote that went forward
that's a different place
i know joe biden still has not left his
house inside there except for a bike
ride
you cannot run a nation you cannot run
the most powerful
nation in the world by staying home and
not going out and talking to the
american public
you cannot win an election without
telling people what you're going to do
for the next four years and you know
last night we were able to show
that the president trump kept his
promises be it build the wall
be it make the military stronger build
the biggest economy we've ever
had criminal justice reform
victory after victory after victory and
we'll lay out that the next four years
will even be better
we'll have complete coverage tonight
last thing does president trump
protesting mail-in voting especially for
states that haven't done it before
does that hurt you in the efforts to get
some members
elected i mean there's some republicans
or independents that obviously
choose to mail in votes in some of those
states and you need to win those seats
well i think people should mail in their
vote what president trump is saying
he wants to make sure that the vote is
collected because
a mail-in vote is different than an
absentee vote a mail-in vote is where
they mail to
everybody who's just whatever on the
list the elections department does not
clean that up we found that in la they
had more than a million people
they're no longer there so you want to
make sure that the absentee vote so when
you get your ballot
make sure you mail it in but do
something more follow it trace it make
sure it's counted if it's not
go to the polls mr leader we appreciate
your time
thank you so much